the sugarcane harvest in western Cuba
has changed little over the centuries
even with the addition of some aging
combine harvesters but after the
Revolution factories that refine the
sugar were nationalized and so were
distillers of perhaps the tastiest end
product rum the drink is everywhere here
especially the government produced brand
Havana Club
but this rum is not the only one with
that name and you cannot buy it in
America due to the blockade is not
possible to to be with a Cuban product
in United States
Sergio Valdez is the export director of
a joint venture founded in 1993 when the
Cuban state partnered with French firm
Pernod Ricard
to sell Cuban produced to ban a club
overseas was it a risk for a French
drinks company to come to Cuba and work
with the government there was a risk
because they knew that the brand cannot
be trade in United State a brand
forbidden in the 40% of the total market
the French firms soon learned the
embargo would not be the only barrier
blocking their Cuban made Havana Club
from the US another rum also called
Havana Club distilled in Puerto Rico
became available in American stores that
doesn't mean that people sailing Havana
Club in United States has the legal
register for the brand the company
currently selling the brand in the US is
Bacardi Mike Dolan is the CEOs do you
make a profit currently from havana club
in the US well be tiny obviously but
even tiny profits create a powerful
legal argument for Bacardi their sales
of just 500 cases a year in only five
states constitute an ongoing use of the
Havana Club brand and that use trumps
any claims of brand ownership from
Pernod Ricard or the Cuban government
this is a business where the competition
is fierce so I think it becomes a
question of really defending what you
own and have a right to that right came
from Congress which backed Bacardi by
passing in 1998 law that the World Trade
Organization said violated America's
treaty obligations
but as us-cuba rhetoric cools the rum
market may well heat up given the recent
news on Cuba I think everyone is looking
at how that affects the big brands and
and and we're looking at it to to say
you know is now the right moment to do
something more aggressively Hana Ricard
told us if the embargo lifts but the
trademark blockade remains they'll
simply start shipping their Cuban Havana
Club under a different name in the
meantime
Bacardi's US sales of a Havana Club
remain barely profitable but their real
value may be in keeping a rival rum out
of America's cocktails